thank you
[Music]
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story The search for Nicola
bully
police say she is high risk and
vulnerable because of significant issues
with alcohol which resurfaced over
recent months
that unusual update issued tonight as it
emerged officers had visited her home
weeks before she disappeared because of
concern over her welfare
also tonight I'm live from hollyrood
after the shock resignation of first
Minister Nicholas sturgeon
stepping down she said was right for her
her party and her country now the
process to replace her
this is really hard for me
my decision comes from a place of Duty
and of Love tough love perhaps but loved
nevertheless for my party and above all
for the country
[Music]
failed to deliver Independence uh final
weeks overshadowed by her stance on
trans rights
also tonight rescued from the rubble we
hear how a split second decision saved
the lives of Two Sisters
and slowing down but not fast enough as
inflation eases why food prices will
stay high for several months
plus we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 30.
[Music]
good evening it's been 19 days since
Nicola bully dropped her children off at
school put her dog on a leash and went
for a walk along the river in the small
village of Saint Michael's on wire in
Lancashire since then her disappearance
has baffled police and Intrigue
Tick-Tock detectives and today as
officers defended their methods they
revealed she'd been classed as high risk
later in an unusual step detectives
confirmed she had problems with alcohol
and that there had been previous
concerns about her welfare Sky's intiman
Rasheed has been following this case
from the very start and joins us now
live Lindsay
well Kamali it's been almost three weeks
since Nicola bully went missing and in
an unusual level of detail released by
police today it has thrown a huge
question mark of confusion over what's
happened that Friday morning when Nicola
bully took her two daughters to school
and then took her dog Willow for a walk
in an unprecedented move by Lancashire
police we learned details of very
private family matters which are now
playing a key role in this missing
person's investigation
the questions keep on mounting but 20
days on one has remained the same what
happened to Nicola bully we now know
this was a mum of two vulnerable with
ongoing struggles
as soon as she was reported missing
following the information that was
provided to the police by her partner
Paul and based on a number of specific
vulnerabilities that we were made aware
of Nicola was graded as high risk but
what was it about Nicola that raised
alarms something police today couldn't
answer
can you just give us a bit more
information about what Nikki's partner
told you about her vulnerabilities I'm
not going to go into the details of
those individual vulnerabilities I've
asked you to respect the family who are
going through unimaginable pain and
distress at this moment it was however a
revelation too important to dismiss
Lancashire police hours after this news
conference revealed what those specific
vulnerabilities were
Nicola had in the past suffered with
some significant issues with alcohol
they said which were brought on by her
ongoing struggles with the menopause and
these struggles had resurfaced over
recent months this has caused some real
challenges for Paul and the family
just 17 days before Nicola disappeared
police and health professionals were
called to her family home they attended
a report for a concern of welfare no one
at the time was arrested but it's being
investigated
after almost three weeks of extensive
searching and a major police operation
investigators have theories but not many
answers those hypotheses included the
one that she possibly could have gone
into the river
that there could have been third party
involvement and lastly that she could
have left the area voluntarily how
confident are you and your team that
you'll find Nicola bully alive
I hope with all my heart that we find
Nicola bully alive more than anything
how confident are you
I have told you that my working
hypothesis is at the moment through all
the information that we have gathered
that the likelihood is that Nicola
has unfortunately gone in the river
finding Nicola is everyone's priority
here it's a wonder how hope hasn't faded
almost three weeks on
details of the troubles she faced will
be no barrier
foreign
Supply here but there will be questions
and maybe huge worries as well about how
these very private details about Nicola
will impact her family her struggles
with alcohol the fact that police went
round to her home on the 10th of January
about concerns for welfare and it was
quite odd police initially today
dismissing these details for them to
come out later and give those details
this evening the last 20 days have been
hellish for Nicholas family and friends
and this level of information will not
help in any way the bottom line is
though Nicola remains missing at home
are her two daughters still without her
mom and there is no clear evidence or
Clues as to where she may be
good evening from Holly Rood at the end
of a momentous day in Scottish politics
this country's longest serving first
Minister and its first female leader
Nicola sturgeon unexpectedly resigned
today saying in my heart and in my head
I know the time is now she suffered
significant setbacks in her campaign for
a second Independence referendum and for
reform of transgender rights but insists
short-term pressures did not inform her
decision well we'll assess Nicola
sturgeon's Legacy coming up and the race
to replace it but first asked Scott and
correspondent Connor Gillis reports now
on a significant moment for Scotland and
the UK
rumor was Rife about the future of a
first minister
in my head and in my heart I know that
time is now
that it is right for me for my party and
for the country
and so today I am announcing my
intention to step down as first Minister
and leader of my party
outside supporters waited opponents
watched as the bombshell dropped the
moment the UK's most senior female
politician called it a day
[Applause]
leaving at a time of a legal standoff
with Downing streets over the Scottish
government making it easier to change
gender something UK ministers are
blocking I am trying to rationally
individually what I'm trying to do is
address the issues quitting weeks after
it emerged a double rapist Adam Graham
now known as Isla Bryson was housed
temporarily in a women's prison this
decision comes from a deeper and longer
term assess
ment do you believe though that the
issues are in particularly the row
around transgender prisoners was the
straw that broke the camel's back here
it's not the case that this decision is
because of short-term issues I've faced
more short-term issues from time to time
over my years in politics than I care to
remember
um and if it was just that I wouldn't be
standing here today make no mistake this
is a major highly significant moment in
UK politics but also leaves the SMP and
the independence cause here in Scotland
in a perilous position Nicholas sturgeon
has failed in that main mission of hers
to deliver a second referendum and it's
unclear when or if that vote will now
happen
the smps hope to lead Scotland to a
different future was dealt a hammer blow
when the Supreme Court ruled Hollywood
could not legally hold a second vote a
moment now to reflect from Nicola
sturgeon's predecessor you'd have
expected having set her course for this
de facto referendum with all the
difficulties it entails that's the one
you would you would see through and
you'd often expect the challenges happen
in politics so the the independence
movement has been led to not a dead end
but certainly a roadblock and her
successor and others in Scotland will
have to to find a way through it and the
search for that successor is now
underway to replace a formidable Force
the figurehead of a movement who's now
preparing for life away from the top job
Conor Gillis Sky News Edinburgh
well Nicholas sturgeon always said she
should be judged by her record and under
her stewardship a party the SNP became
an electoral Juggernaut he was a leading
Force for Scottish independence of
course but failed to deliver a second
referendum vote and today visibly moved
she said that no job would come close to
being first Minister Sky's political
editor Beth Rigby assesses her Legacy
[Applause]
a leader at the height of her power here
Nicholas sturgeon cleaning up in the
2019 general election
all the wild dominant in Scottish
politics too as the longest serving
first minister of Scotland
the first woman to lead the country
and the first whose departure from high
office has not involved death defeat or
scandal
Korea spanning too in two decades
punctuated with great highs
but also lows leaving office her Mission
unfulfilled
Nicholas Sergeant was born in 1970 in
airshare this part of West Scotland and
labor Heartland but with Margaret
Thatcher in power it was the SMP she
joined at the age of 16. in the late
1980s as Alex salmond attempted to make
his mark on Westminster Nicholas
sturgeon was in Glasgow studying law
debating and campaigning quiet serious
and focused she's soon impressed within
the SMP later becoming her party's
Deputy leader and then Deputy first
minister to Mr salmond the man she
described as her mentor
she soon formalized another relationship
marrying Peter Morrell the snp's
longtime chief executive
[Applause]
a year later and an SMP majority at
Hollywood in 2011 meant a mandate for an
independence referendum and a huge
opportunity for Nicholas sturgeon
after the pro-independence campaign lost
the 2014 vote and Alex salmond resigned
the dream shall never die
it was that dream that Nicholas Sargent
inherited succeed in him as Scotland's
fast female Premiere a modern and
confident Scotland fit for purpose and
fit for all of her people and out of
salmon Shadows Sergeant Sean the 2015
election her breakout moment it simply
cannot be and it will not be business as
usual when it comes to westminster's
dealing with Scotland
the SMP almost wiped out Scottish labor
and have been the third party at
Westminster ever since will a change of
leadership shift that landscape to I'm
not complacent labor has to set out new
ideas New Vision and a new passion for
how we build a more prosperous future
for Scotland and it is a significant
moment a significant opportunity but
that means I was setting out what that
positive change looks like and I relish
the opportunity to do that a strong
performer Nicholas Dodge and impressed
in the 2015 TV debates a master of the
selfie II all helping to build an image
of a modern political leader but when it
came to policy her record much more
mixed there's no doubt that she was
successful at The Ballot Box in terms of
using that power and there were there
were key feelings one of them was the
education attainment Gap when she said
she would close she made that promise
that never happened Scotland has got a
shameful drugs death record that barely
shifted as well and look at kiosks in
the hill service from the GP service
through the AE and also in the
ambulances there's no doubt that
Nicholas Sergeant's domestic record is
very patchy Scottish
as she continued at The Ballot Box UK
prime ministers came and went
Nicholas sturgeon of Thorne in the side
of successive PMs and less prickly
relationship with her latest counterpart
but their political objectives miles
apart let me first start by paying
tribute to Nicholas sturgeon for her
long-standing public service and I wish
her well in the future I've consistently
said that I think what people in
Scotland want to see is their two
governments a Scottish government and
the UK government working constructively
together on the priorities that really
matter to people
brexit another fault line between
Hollywood and Westminster opposed by the
majority of Scots it reignited the
question of Scottish independence again
but failed to get Nicholas sturgeon much
closer to an independence vote the
Supreme Court ruling last year that
Hollywood does not have the power to
legislate for a referendum on Scottish
independence
Hollywood overruled two over the rights
for transgender people as the government
in Westminster blocked a quality
legislation over the fears for the
impact on safe spaces for females
but Nicholas sturgeon's potent
combination of communication and
political skills proved invaluable
during the pandemic she was widely
praised for her leadership even though
mistakes were made and many thousands
died
but soon after came perhaps her lowest
moment when the Scottish government's
botched mishandling of harassment
complaints against Alex salmond and Miss
sturgeon's role since turned a
friendship into a bitter Feud I will
tell the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth by choosing the
timing of her departure Nicholas
Sergeant Remains the master of her own
destiny but she leaves office having
failed to determine Scotland's that
second referendum further away and a
vacuum at the top of her party
Scotland's political land shape has
shifted and not necessarily to the smp's
advantage
well the process to replace Nicola
sturgeon is already underway once the
first Minister has tended her
resignation to the king then the
Scottish Parliament has 28 days to
nominate a successor but first the SNP
must choose a new leader candidates must
have at least 100 nominations from party
members from at least 20 local branches
if more than one candidate receives the
required nominations there will be a
postal vote
Front Runners so far include the
bookmaker's favorite Angus Robertson a
former SNB Westminster leader now
Constitution external Affairs and
culture secretary
Kate Forbes the Scottish Finance
secretary is also well regarded she is
currently on maternity leave
the health secretary Hamza yusaf is also
in the running as well as a former party
leader John Sweeney currently Deputy
first Minister and acting Finance
secretary well let's talk live now to
Beth and Bethany search then for a
successor already started after the end
of a quite significant era in Scottish
politics
yes dominant and let's reflect on that
era because it really is someone who
dominated Scottish politics for over two
decades now bowing out Nicholas sturgeon
saying today that she knew in her head
and her heart that it was time and the
job of the intensity takes its toll a
friend of hers told me that she had had
enough that she wanted to get her life
back and she'd become worn down by the
internal wranglings within the SMP but
this is far more than just about the
personal politics of Nicholas sturgeon
at the heart of this decision I think is
an admission by the fast Minister that
she really has run out of road when it
comes to trying to force that second
referendum it has been her life's work
it was what has driven her politics for
over two decades and her standing down I
think is an admission that it is not
going to happen in the foreseeable
future and she herself has perhaps run
out of ideas so where it leaves a second
referendum his father in into the
distance where it leaves the SMP is at a
difficult point because she has been so
dominant in Scottish politics she's
effectively handing over the Baton to a
new generation hoping that they will
come out with the ideas to build
momentum that she is clearly losing and
then finally what does it mean for UK
politics it's a huge moment for the
labor party they came in with just one
MP in the 2019 general election out of
59 45 seats go into the SMP Nicholas
sturgeon has pretty much wiped them out
in Westminster over the past three
general elections so for labor this is a
huge opportunity a senior politician in
labor saying to me today this is the
moment where they hope they can rebuild
trust with Scottish voters another
saying to me that they're always happy
to see a winner bow out of the race so
huge opportunity for labor huge
uncertainly in Scotland in big
ramifications for both hollyrood and
Westminster with the departure of
Nicholas sturgeon as fast minister
okay Beth Rigby thank you very much well
much has been made of Nicholas
sturgeon's political Legacy but how did
her decades in politics change the lives
of Voters here well Tom Palmetto
traveled to Victoria Road in the south
side of Glasgow to find out
nothing stays still
but the south side of Glasgow has become
very used to Nicholas sturgeon even if
they don't all agree with her she's done
a great job um taking on the Tories
um nobody else uses fun with the boys
hot and showing all our opponents for
the past eight years out showing them
all what do you think her Legacy will be
as Government she's the longest server a
failure yeah NHS is a mess schools
education
thank you that already through Corvette
I think she did her best
um but it just feels like that was our
Peak and it's all just kind of went a
little bit then pill from there
Nicola sturgeon says she wants a more
normal life but will still represent
glasgow's south side and fight her
political battles from here including of
course the snp's push for Independence
hi guys welcome to
opinion polls still have Scotland split
down the middle at imran's restaurant he
sees the current first Minister as
integral to Independence I feel as if
we've heard departing like this it's
going to crumble why
I think purely because she was the
backbone to this Pro referendum
pro-independence you know and um now
with her departure it's all will come
down crumbly evening drinks at the Bell
jar Malcolm helps run the yes campaign
in this part of the city what it does is
introduce a degree of uncertainty in how
things will be in the short term I mean
I think Nicola's going in her own terms
um and uh
and she feels that she's a divisive
figure for people who don't want
independence and therefore maybe it will
open the door to more people coming over
to Independence uh time will tell
in the city center those who said no to
Independence held a brief Street party
the first Minister has to somehow
represent and serve everyone
after eight years on this ride it's time
for someone else
Tom Parmenter Sky News Glasgow
let's bring in our Scotland
correspondent Connor Gillis and Connor
how then did life change here under
Nicholas sturgeon and what's next well
things have changed a lot very
dramatically over the course of Nicholas
sturgeon's Premiership here in Scotland
eight years in the top job for Nicholas
sturgeon her supporters would point to
her achievements over the course of the
last couple of years putting additional
money into the pockets of the poorest
families here in Scotland and of course
those emphatic wins in each and every
election that she has fought her Critics
on the other hand have a very different
view she leaves her job they say in a
situation where she's failed to deliver
or Advance the cause of Independence she
has failed to deliver a key Pledge on
education closing the attainment gap for
those from the most deprived backgrounds
and of course she leaves this position
at a time when Scotland's drug deaths
are among the worst in Europe now unlike
with Alex salmon back in 24 14 there is
no clear successor for who takes over
from Nicholas sturgeon I did speak to
Keith Brown at the current Deputy leader
of the SNP the current Justice secretary
here in Scotland he didn't rule out that
he may be stepping into The Fray as part
of who comes next but nominations are
now open and the smp's national
executive committee will meet tomorrow
night to discuss exactly what happens
next okay Connor gellis Thank you very
much
now there was a split second decision
which likely saved the lives of Two
Sisters as the earthquake struck and
their apartment building crumbled a
rhino zainab and Elite for safety
underneath their bed Sky's John Sparks
witnessed their rescue some four days
later and spoke to them in hospital
afterwards in the Turkish city of
kalaman Mirage from where he sent this
report
the people of caramel Mirage have begun
to reclaim their community
after the earthquakes destroyed much of
the city
but there are acts of courage and
endurance they can draw on here
from a small number who were rescued
from the rubble
and each one has a tale of Wonder
um
were imprisoned within the remains of
their seven-story apartment building
and would spend more than four days
without food Water and Light
they were freed by an Israeli and
Turkish rescue team and we managed to
capture the moment
I could see you in your pajamas you were
shivering I wonder what it was like a
bit
all of them
I mean
early in the morning of February the 6th
zainab discovered her bedroom was
shaking from side to side
she then made a life-saving decision
so
um
the pair soon realized they were stuck
under zainab's bed with absolutely no
means of Escape
exactly
the message
it was damp and it was cold the
temperature plunged below zero at night
so they held on to each other to keep
warm did you ever lose hope inside all
the songs
many of those who lived in their
neighborhood have lost their lives
we saw local volunteers trying to
retrieve the bodies wedged between the
cracks of concrete
an unknown number have not been found
zainab and alife's mother and father are
also missing and their daughters are
deeply concerned they haven't seen them
since the first earthquake struck
foreign
both sisters suffered cuts and bruising
they were badly dehydrated and feel
desperately tired
but the pair are glad to be alive I
wonder how you think this experience
would change your mind you
know
um
their story of resilience shines like a
light in this devastated City
where sorrow and loss hang heavy in the
air
John Sparks Sky News in caravan Mirage
okay time now for a look at some of
tonight's other news and the former
leader of the labor party Jeremy corbyn
has hit back at secure starman's
decision to block him from standing as a
labor candidate at the next general
election Corbin called a flagrant attack
on the Democratic rights of party
members in his constituency of Islington
North sakir spoke this morning after the
equalities Watchdog found the labor
party had vastly improved how it deals
with allegations of anti-semitism
we love our kids we're never going no
neighborhood to take people out
well this was during the sentencing of
the hearing for a white supremacist who
killed 10 black people at a supermarket
in Buffalo in New York in May of last
year an unidentified family member of
someone who died charged at Peyton
Gendron in the court minutes before he
was sentenced to life in prison without
parole
now the cost of living is rising at a
lower rate than had been predicted
according to the latest figures out
today inflation was running at 10.1
percent in January compared with 10.5
percent back in December but some prices
are still rising at even more
eye-watering rates food went up almost
17 last month our business correspondent
gurpreet narwan reports
but when it comes to the food shop the
cost of living is still biting
Sally a single mom from ilford says
she's struggling to keep up for me I
think it doesn't haven't gone down it's
just going up and up and up you have
family you have kids you need to feed
them it's not only the food they have
like you'll need extra extra things that
you have to buy for them your fridge
have to have like healthy food and
everything so all your wages are going
there
didn't go up but the food is just taking
all my wages it's tough on everyone it's
a common concern you come today he said
t-bound 50. you come back tomorrow it's
2.70 and he's like a slap on your face
and I've come across a couple of people
that stopped to get their shopping done
and then you have to talk them off which
is really sad but there are some
glimmers of Hope official figures show
that the headline rate of inflation has
fallen for three consecutive months now
after peaking at 11.1 in October it fell
to 10.1 percent in January but food
prices kept rising robustly at a rate of
16.7 percent the Figures were in line
with forecasts published by the bank of
England which thinks inflation will fall
consistently over the coming months
the rate of inflation may be slowing but
that will provide very little relief to
households who are already struggling
with their everyday costs
food prices for example are still
climbing at their fastest Pace in
decades that will soon start slowing but
it doesn't mean prices will be coming
down from where they already are
further up the supply chain wholesalers
say they are battling with costs from
energy to raw materials which are
forcing them to keep prices high for
prices to start coming down I think
we're looking at the back end of the
Sierra if I'm honest I don't see and
certainly none of my colleagues in the
business see a change in the next four
four to five months so we are looking
really probably six months ahead for any
relief for consumers for the moment then
things shouldn't get any worse but they
aren't getting any better either garprit
nawan steinies
now she became famous after wearing a
fur bikini tonight's tributes are being
paid to Raquel Welch one of the most
famous Hollywood stars of the 60s and
70s who's died at the age of 82.
[Music]
let's do a great admiration for Michael
York well one girl wouldn't oh well she
was picturing
a queen mother in 1974 starred in films
such as Fantastic Voyage and one Million
Years BC and won a Golden Globe for her
role in The Three Musketeers her agent
said that she died following a brief
illness